hi welcome back to Nintendo treehouse
live at e3 2017 we're going to take a
look at a new game
sushi striker the way of sushi dough
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sushi honeyBun
guy night man
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
came home today you be good
my leg
yeah
Scoob oh I do
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that is that is the coolest intro
to a game I could ever imagine I love
that song yeah I make it very I'm rich
I'm here with Teresa and Cory and yeah
everybody's a fan of that song we have
to we have to get that yeah so why don't
you go ahead and introduce this game
yeah so this is this is sushi striker
the way of sushi dough um the developers
Indies are oh you might know them from
any nes remix and so the game you could
either play as a boy or a girl but I'm
gonna pick a boy and so as we go you can
see here that the map is actually pretty
substantially big but obviously my save
data hasn't been played up very long so
I'm actually gonna start here in the
first area and the story is in a
post-war era setting where two sides
have been fighting for the rights to
sushi supply and these mystical beings
that really love sushi are masters of
sushi exists this boy mr. Goro Musashi
they leave their village on a really
empty stomach and they encounter this
man that ends up feeding them sushi for
the very first time and we saw she
thinks that this thing is the most
amazing delicious food ever he's never
had it before
it never loses a little mine yes and so
but unfortunately their encounter gets
you know disrupted very quickly due to a
notorious organization but that becomes
a catalyst of Musashi encountering a
mythical being that specializes in in
sushi and they he decides to share his
power with him and then they decide to
go off on this journey to become the
ultimate sushi striker pretty
straightforward right yeah I think it is
yeah anyway now I should say that this
game is obviously it's all in Japanese
and very much in development right now
so we're pretty lucky to take this
earlier look at it but I think it's
really rather
you enjoy it so let's go into our
hospital all right so this is a puzzle
action game and as you can see here both
myself and the opponent have three
layers three legs of sushi and similar
to real life conveyor belt sushi the
place symbolize well in real life
conveyor belt sushi the plates symbolize
a price right but here it actually
amounts to the amount of damage that you
can reflect in your opponent yep so what
you're trying to do is actually change
plates yeah to make a really big stack
if you're gonna have the touch screen on
the bottom bottom screen there that's
right and so I did say that each person
has three conveyor belts but there's
actually one on top of my screen that's
a gold one and that's actually shared so
either myself or any opponent can
actually take from that belt and the
other thing too is that you have seven
seconds to create your chain if you try
to hold on to it and try to make a stack
as as much as you can't you lose that
sack which that would have been an
awesome stack yeah I just wanted it from
a brain yeah but the other thing too is
that you can lose it if it goes off
screen right you gotta act fast to get
that sushi so you're you're curling
these plates at the opponent it looks
like your health is at the top of the
bottom screen so that's you've got about
4,000 or so your opponent's got a little
over 3,000 in the red bar up there in
this sushi battle and I definitely want
to strategize like I see that there's a
lot of green plates here so I'm gonna
try to make or
played so I'm going to try to make it a
little bit late and you'll see that I'll
start accruing five stacks on the bottom
screen and so if I make an actual six
stack that automatically curls to the
opponent but I could also just grab it
and throw it at him right the change
that I make actually will build this
Lantern meter that's at the top of the
touchscreen and so once it fills up I'm
going to try here
nice Oh therapy oh not yet there we go
massage she gets like super empowered
there's more plates of similar color so
I can make change a lot easier and then
there's also a multiplier of added to
the stacks that are on the bottoms touch
screen and with that that means that the
multiplier in the stacks do much more
damage so I'm actually going to end my
opponent here I just woke them as they
say of eating those sushi and throwing
your plates at the opponent Oh like I
get more powerful by eating more sushi
right I mean I wish that was in your
life because anyone who's been to a
conveyor belt sushi restaurants knows
the feeling of like right when you get
done with your meal you have that huge
stack of plates right that's how your
bill is determined yeah so you'll see
here that I got a C rank unfortunately I
didn't do that well that's okay but it's
related to my score but there's also
these three stars and those are actually
related to the objectives that I've
accomplished within that level right and
also here you'll see that both Musashi
and their companions are leveled up
according to the levels that you're able
to successfully win really cannot
actually go into more detail right yeah
we'll do that next
so actually quarry why don't you take a
stab yeah give it a try here thank you
yeah
so you were talking about those
companions if you see our little white
fluffy guy who is our little companion
here that's right so the little lion
character s right there the opponent
uses unicorn characters ability which is
sped up the lanes
we saw she has this lion character and
his power up you'll see the green bar
that's next to hit his face on the
touchscreen it actually slowly increases
depending on the sushi type that Musashi
eats and each companion will have an
affinity to specific sushi and that will
change as they level up throughout the
game and obviously they'll become more
powerful
each of these content of these
characters they actually have a special
ability so the unicorn sped up the the
lanes but the line character has
different abilities which hopefully
querying along it will just showed
yeah go crazy again
oh all right Cory here we go yeah there
you go so now it's ready and what
happens is all the plates that are on
this active screen turn into a single
color and that allows for Cory to chain
all these plates into a single large
step right I'm sure that you miss back
there in the middle yeah I know his a
lantern meter this it allows for the
special mode and it's added all these up
hires out of ice cream so great look at
that place nice oh you should totally
paralyzed right huh yes so you have two
ways of attacking the enemies either
it'll drop off automatically when you
fill up another row or you can actually
manually swipe them up swipe up on the
screen and throw this plate set at the
opponent that's right she's pretty great
it's very satisfying you know when
they've been dealing a lot of damage to
you and you have the option oh s right
good huh you sent me a prospectus thank
you I thought that would be a challenge
considering he did executed that move
like right at the beginning you have me
fooled great job all right
so we're gonna go to another level I'm
going to ask for you to play this one
too but before we do I'm actually going
to add more companion so in this game
you're actually you're able to get more
companions as you keep playing through
the game so I'm going to add this
electric
and I'm gonna add this let's do yelling
I like that guy yeah oh let's do that
[Music]
and each companion has their own ability
so again you have to keep strategizing
as to you know if you find that a level
is too hard you might want to keep going
to previous levels and keep leveling up
so you become stronger or you can try to
find another companion to use during
that and try to get the upper hand it
gets your approach yeah and you can see
them all the bottom left now right those
are all of my companions so their bars
are going to fill up as they eat
particular kinds of sushi that's right
but your opponent also has three
companions especially now so it's even
it's three against three
great does that locked sushi we play I
want it
oh that's right so you'll see that the
gold conveyor belts at the very top any
touchscreen there's these covered plates
and that actually has a lantern and you
definitely its lock of it so you have to
get that certain number of plates in
order to grab onto it and you definitely
want to get it before your opponent
because again it turns I don't my yellow
cat lantern yellow cat is ready oh so
what he does is if you throw the place
it has an electric buff that when you
throw it against the enemy it does that
extra damage which I personally like
that's my favorite one it's awesome and
so you see in the bottom right-hand
corner of the bottom screen you know
that like a live camera feed that shows
you sort of a different type of reaction
you see the enemy eating his section
right my penguin is ready as well oh
it's desserts
awesome so tapping these desserts will
replenish your health and that can be
handy especially when you're in a tight
spot
absolutely yeah it's gonna be just the
unleash of electric attacks on Cory
that each period actually come in handy
so you're saying that live feed yeah
that actually interchanges between you
and the opponent depending on the
highlights of the battle yeah
really fun to watch you know you don't
have necessarily all the time in the
world when you're playing this game it
is pretty hectic when you're in there
you get you got to focus on your lanes
but yeah great job done hungry that is
an effect that this game has on people
be nice not bad it's fun to identify
some of the sushi in the game too right
got like traditional salmon
you've got your California rolls for
fans of sushi in here in the US and got
your your egg tuna my favorite meal I'm
feeling that playing this game will make
you hungry I'm already hungry just
talking about right okay so I'm actually
to switch it up and put in different
characters but I also want to show I'm
actually gonna keep my electric guy cuz
I really like them he's my favorite
I put the cat this character and I'm
also so this screen here actually I can
put on to other companion our characters
that I'm not really using but so what
will happen is that they're in my party
and even though I'm not actively using
them they will level up as I'm playing a
level and that's actually very handy
because in the circumstance that I
decided to switch companions later on
down the road I could just easily swap
them out and not have to worry about
leveling them up because they're ready
being leveled as I keep playing yeah
that's awesome they level in tandem so
yeah that really adds the diversity of
what you can do yeah in battle and makes
strategizing a lot easier yep so this is
a boss battle and he is really really
brutal I don't know if I'm gonna make it
but I'm definitely gonna try oh good
luck oh my gosh he is making massive
stacks
yeah that boy Oh special characters that
uh are pretty Oh P is also not wearing a
shirt that's how I roll yeah nice stack
there you go yep some companions ready
oh that's right
yeah one thing I think you mentioned is
that it's tough to know whether or not
to get that multiplayer multiplier by
sticking with the same type of sushi or
should you just say no I just need the
plates and just go for the same color
plate yes sometimes that multiplayer
will actually do more damage with west
plates than the same amount of plates
with different sushi nice oh there we go
your hold your own there yeah I'm trying
[Applause]
of course we're showing single-player
right now there will be a two-player
mode in this game oh my gosh I'm
mesmerized by your stacking skills here
get the eel
oh my god nothing here yeah he destroys
me every time he's he's pretty
challenging yeah sure well please look
forward to this game coming out in 2018
but for right now do stay tuned for the
2017 arms open Invitational it's going
to be some pretty awesome arms gameplay
going on so look forward to it thanks
guys thank you